getting Jimmy with it no getting jiggy
with it no no no no no no no no nothing
makes a bad guy layer look more like a
bad guy layer and cardboard boxes and
camo nets
this is Jay got his daughter like I've
ever seen you smile ear to ear way more
than all the other years that see what
you've done to me you sometimes wear
shorts what I know dude I wore dad
shorts the other day 6 pocket minimum
just a super huge fat ass and you're
like I hate this guy so much I'm gonna
kill him with my pistol because he's
going for his perfect 3 2 1 action slow
[Music]
is this met no this is a liquid vapor
equilibrium there's this alcohol
solution in here that is just at the
tipping point between being a vapor or
liquid so using heat from my hand I'm
now pushing liquid up through the tube
just from the heat from my hand here and
if I was to actually put my hand here
it's gonna go back down
we need more heat this is much safer
with a blow dryer but I only have a heat
gun so when I use a heat gun I'm gonna
burn my hand
see how the liquids going up to the top
now if I go to the top it is going to
push it all the way back down
oh man this is hot science this is
actually very similar to another
phenomenon known as the triple point of
water that is when you have a jar filled
with water but you have three states of
matter you have liquid ice and boiling
water vapour all in the same jars
because you put enough pressure and heat
all in the same mixture you reach what
is called the triple point and this is
similar so basically when I add a heat
to this bottom thing there the gas
expands pushing the liquid up through
the pipe to the top it's pretty cool
there's another thing gyroscopes man
so gyroscopes are from like way back in
the day nowadays we use electronic
gyroscopes to tell orientation cool
thing about a gyroscope is that has like
this flywheel thing on my god strings
I'm not good at knitting man so for my
blood you pull on it now it's spinning
really fast look at that now that it's
rotating so fast it's actually creating
a force going straight through the
center of the circle okay no I don't
like using the strings there's got to be
a better way in it can I get you help
real quick check this out
just hold this string
[Applause]
see how it's just dangling on his side
it's not falling it should be falling
but it doesn't because it now that the
momentum has actually started dying it
now it's just hanging there hey Google
for some really cool people Andrew
Ryan's room and Calvin Kingdom and John
Welch also so so is here oh and also
Richard Blackburn and James Bailey and
don't forget Adam J Tilly and those are
our patreon supporters thank you guys so
much for supporting us you make these
videos possible without you guys who
wouldn't be able to make any videos like
this next one it says all variously
please help me to keep it here locked up
this is peter number 42 I've been stuck
in the next dimension and I can't get
out don't put me away again so you don't
please don't please don't please don't
please don't please don't leave though
so last week we asked you guys to send
us gifts of your favorite moments in the
same anikó channel so now we're gonna
sit down and check those out first one
nyborg Shock Troopers gif
that's a choreo again just go fight it
Oh Stephen hob the man sorry guys I'm
gonna shred these gifts apart when
quarter of all that was wrong use that a
new style of meme text please when your
pizza is delivered true truly go true
dude just a hair ball to be a hairball
to ride me Oh find [ __ ] blown that's
like one of those multi yeah this is
sorry one where you send in the text
message high-utility yeah get for any
patient help if your I can buy
yeah Randy's his karate to fix PC cuz I
have no way back then oh man he was like
2 years old when they're in no time dude
that's a sick name title oh this is all
it help me hi guys sorry it's something
great
sorry Suffolk right your dad joins us no
fight oh okay I think this is one of our
videos at first it is just a shot of bad
jokes my mouth disappears 118 or Google
that's enough rest
okay Google Google that's enough goggle
hey Google Google hey Google system that
Ok Go Go Go move without about Google
can't learn why'd you do this it's so
this is pretty funny but mostly just a
shot of him furiously one wheeling
torsion that was probably your best
stunt ever this one couldn't really hurt
me if I messed it up got one friend whoa
whoa whoa
I love that it's like big lots of the
where's yeah wait how do that is
continent let you do that
how do you do that that was pretty good
I'd you classic bread oh yeah this is a
great good you'll miss a lot of uh some
of the shots you don't take control sure
I need an amazin ice sick sound effects
Jake me with hey Google tell me a story
supporting here oh dude this guy's this
guy that is a finalist
Oh Tom I closed a dollar inappropriate
landlord I'd like that a lot but it's
not a workingman's gift though ya know
look at this right everybody look at me
this is a beautifully composed shows
beautiful oh oh utility give to the
madness
oh dude yeah it's like the Olympics you
can get 11th place and still an honor
number one Sam giving us the finger
number two distorted Ren face number
three high percent of the shots you
don't take in number four render time
under one hour so there's a lot of great
significance and ego channel is so
capable
you guys have proven me wrong so thank
you so much for sending stuff in there's
really cool we'll have to do another
gift Film Festival sometime soon
also we're gonna have to surprise Ren
way more often I'm shooting fireworks
off or like just like freaking out or
giving them really good or bad news